Intel just announced the fastest laptop
chip ever it is an absolute beast and it
looks like it is going to smoke Apple's
upcoming M2 Max in the 16 inch MacBook
Pro so in this video I'll give you guys
all of the info how it's going to
compare to Apple's M2 Max as well as
some other issues and performance
numbers that we have seen now this ship
is called the I9
13980 HX chip when that stands for
mobile processor it is the highest end
one that they have and it runs up to
5.6 gigahertz in clock speed now that is
absolutely crazy of course it's gonna
have to be cooled enough uh to reach
that speed and to keep it up which we'll
talk about in just a bit but it is also
a 24 core
processor which in and of itself is
pretty crazy the M2 Max well that thing
is going to be a 12 core out of those 24
cores it has eight performance cores
along with 16 efficiency cores and it
supports up to 128 gigabytes of RAM so
that's a good amount of ram it is also
Ultra fast now compared to the previous
generation Intel said that this thing is
11 faster in single threaded performance
and up to 49 faster for multitasking and
the performance that I'm seeing is
absolutely insane now the previous 12
channel chip was already crazy powerful
beat out the M1 Max everything but the
ultra and this new chip looks like it
even beats out the ultra now before I
compare it to the leaked benchmarks of
the M2 Max let me show you the
performance numbers that we already have
this right here is ranking from
cinebench and if you take a look at this
we have 2
1098 as far as single core score and 26
711 for multi-core that is absolutely
insane for a laptop the M1 Ultra Max
studio that we tested scored 23
991 so it literally is beaten out by
Intel's new laptop chip now for those of
you guys out there saying this is insane
how much power does this thing suck and
how much heat does it put out that is
the appropriate question because it
needs 157 watts to reach the maximum
Turbo Power in a laptop that is insane
now what's crazier is that the
processor's base power is 55 Watts the
Max studio Max is out at 60 watts
maximum and the 16 inch MacBook Pro Pro
with the M1 Max that hits a maximum of
30 Watts but a lot of times for both
those they actually run under when
you're fully loading those systems and
Intel is saying you need a minimum of 45
Watts designed in your laptop to be able
to make sure this processor will run so
that is crazy now before I do that
comparison we'll just talk about battery
life when we test it out uh the MSI
Creator laptop that one was powerful
with a 12th gen processors it's a great
laptop as long as you have it plugged in
but as soon as you unplug it well the
performance goes down not only in the
CPU but also the GPU and of course the
battery life is nothing compared to the
16 inch MacBook Pro on that thing you
can run three and a half four hours of
heavy rendering like we have done with
blender you can do video editing photo
editing and you'll still have a laptop
that works whereas on the Windows
laptops well they slow down a lot and
then the battery life could be even
under an hour on something that is as
insane as this so these are not really
laptops they're more like desktop
Replacements at least if you want to
have the full level of performance Now
intel really advertises their efficiency
cores and that sounds nice it sounds
efficient and this thing has 16
efficiency cores but they are not the
same thing as you will find in Apple's
M2 chips this form user on Mac Rumors
made a great Point Intel and efficient
in one sentence is an oxymoron and even
though this has efficiency cores they're
not mainly for power efficiency but for
area efficiency because four of the
efficiency cores take up roughly the die
space of one performance but two of the
cores are actually performing the same
as a single performance core 4 so that
means for easier tasks that don't need
as high as frequency or don't benefit
from that they could do that or if they
need to have something that has a lot of
performance and the maximum they can use
those larger ones so it's not really
designed for maximum efficiency as you
guys see by those wattages they are
super high but just better use of the
processor whereas Apple's efficiency
cores like I made in my efficiency video
you can put into low power mode in the
CPU and GPU both went down to less than
two watts each and gave us roughly 15
hours of battery life on the M2 MacBook
Air because they are incredibly
efficient and they have great
performance and the system can just run
on that where here your battery life is
not going to be good and of course with
having to have that laptop plugged in
using a lot of power or bad battery life
on but we also have the issue of noise
like this user said where even opening
up and importing photos to Lightroom
kicked up the fans crazy high to cool it
down and of course we've talked about
that many times we've seen it ourselves
because it's a lot of heat that is being
put out which is why we love our
MacBooks now with all of that said we
still have to compare the performance
these Benchmark numbers here are
insanely good and scoring 21 090 in
geekbench or
26981 in cinebench well that will
absolutely destroy even the best leaks
that we have from the M2 Max in our last
update we showed you guys the latest
leaks where we saw the clock speed go up
to
3.68 gigahertz and that gave us better
performance uh whereas of course this
goes up to 5.6 much higher we saw a
single course of
2027 finally whereas this new chip gets
2
118. now for multi-core the best score
we have for the M2 Max is 14
888 compared to 21
090. that is 70 better performance than
the best M2 Max lead that's a huge
difference now as far as cinebench uh we
haven't seen numbers before but we did
get one week this was posted on Mac
rumors as well showing the M2 Max
getting 15
310 for multi-core now we found this
info is from nanorreview.com now here
they have a lot of different information
including June 1st 2023 for release now
that is crazy the chip is still arm V8
it is the Mt Max the cores and threads
match up but interestingly the turbo
boost frequency is 3.5 which lines up to
the first geekbench leaks at lower
performance but not the higher
1488 one so this cinebench R23
multi-core score of 15465 that could go
up but we know that it will still not
compete with 26
981 that is just an absolutely insane
difference of performance now we made
many videos talking about uh the
performance it's a minor jump over the
M1 Max there's going to be efficiency
improvements with the new efficiency
cores that come with the end to M2 Chip
might be three in anime is depending on
what performance we get so we'll have to
see but Apple once again is no longer
playing the maximum performance route
trying to do crazy chips in there but a
nice overall machine that is very
powerful and that can run full
performance on battery with great
battery life and overall it's a great
machine not something that is very big
very thick very heavy that needs to be
plugged in like the results with this
chip from this Asus that came out where
it literally is an 18 inch laptop this
thick boy to be able to handle this chip
and probably not even a full performance
you guys let me know what you think uh
is this kind of performance something
you guys want or would you rather have a
16 inch MacBook Pro that less
performance but that is nice and well
balanced and do you want Apple to try to
compete with Intel in terms of Maximum
performance now if you guys want to
check out a 16 inch MacBook Pro with the
M1 Max you could buy right now at a
great deal check out the YouTube
Shopping product page that's right over
there it pops up click above to
subscribe to see more videos like this
one check out those ones right over
there and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]